first i was like how do i repay both of
you
for doing this for me how do i repay you
what's a gift i can give you we're all
repaying each other no no i wanted to
give you something big so i decided i
need to give you
you
and by you i mean penn badgley what
is this is this where i say something
[Applause]
everybody
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Applause]
hold on
wow look your best get get together
i'm actually sick and i'm in london
but i'm good we could take care of you
yes
um this baby comes right off
we
love you
i can't believe we're talking to you
this is so crazy i i was worried that i
was gonna believe i'm talking to you oh
my god i was worried no no we were gonna
summon weird people to our lives because
we kept talking about why couldn't we be
loved the way you love but yeah and why
didn't you put me in a glass box and and
starve me and leave me from the world if
it's you
she would stand outside my window and
care about what i was thinking and
behaving and feeling and i just i know
[Music]
i'm sorry
there's so many reasons that that can't
happen there's a lot of
um
but i honestly i'm like i'm really uh
like honored and and humbled that i mean
this is a genuine reaction and i feel
like pretty good i don't know
also it's very it's very touching you're
so wonderful and i love you more than a
killer yeah you you slay and i love you
and gossip girl i love your movies i
love you and then i have celebrated you
for many a decade and you can consider
me pom-poms out for many more to come
[Applause]
may we ask what you're up to um you're
in london
you know not feeling up to snuff and yet
you're here chicken soup will be on the
way
and i like your longer hair and that's
just a side bar
just turned into josie grocery i was
like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know we can make it a real
i'm so proud of my friends for playing
it so cool when you came on stream
obviously
you can go to netflix to watch the
incredibly
well-acted most beautifully performed
you
you
you you you and ken by the way has a new
podcast coming out called podcrushed
um where did you come up with that name
it's so good yeah
that is actually uh my one of my
producing partners that was her idea
because it's about it's about middle
school it's really about that formative
period of life that can be humiliating
and profound and everything in between
and people are sending in their real
stories and then i narrate them which is
a lot of fun
wow i like that i
wow are we alive i don't think i don't
know what's happening is
it says on the monitor we'll be right
back
i guess
[Music]
you